dak prescott cowboys quarterback with
comments to usa today after it became
clear that he would not have a long-term
contract he plays under the franchise
tag this year there was a tweet from his
brother yesterday
suggesting
frustration on the part of the family
and maybe an idea that dak prescott is
not going to be with the cowboys for
very long prescott said i'm a cowboy and
couldn't be happier well he's a cowboy
now he's a cowboy this year it's
determined for 2020. what is it
determined is what happens next year and
i've had so many fans say oh dak
prescott shouldn't assume he's gonna
make 37.68 million next year the cowboys
may not be able to afford to tag him
again they may not want to tag him again
okay fine number one they're gonna have
to find another quarterback if that's
the case number two
he goes to the nice bitter
see he he's a winner here either way
he's getting 31.4 million for this year
he still makes a decent amount of money
and by decent i mean in the seven
figures off the field in endorsements
he's got the money to buy an insurance
policy to protect him against a
catastrophic injury that would take away
that big pile of guaranteed money he's
eventually going to get okay fine next
year the cowboys need to pay him 37.68
million or they sign him to a long-term
contract or
they let him walk away in free agency
and he becomes the the new kirk cousins
who signs a three-year 110 million
dollar contract or something like that
on the open market it's
it's good for him either way
setting aside everything beyond 2020 the
guy's getting 31.4 million this year
what's he got to be upset about so
uncertainty as to the future but no
uncertainty as to 2020 at least as it
relates to who the quarterback will be
for the cowboys we don't know whether or
not they're gonna play any games but we
do know that if they ultimately suit up
and go it will be dak prescott at
quarterback all season long
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports